[Music]
on what
just like my old one
what about us there's only one that's
some beetles find something anything we
must fly
[Music]
they were the only roomies left the man
said be careful they have a mind of
their own he's right
just focus we must fly to our ancestral
cottage get booked and brew our potion
and then what would he then work then we
run amok in salem
don't make me come over there with this
blue
[Music]
forever
[Music]
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting
happy 16th birthday child
i have a gift for my favorite customers
legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her power
where did you get that candle we have to
get out of here the witches will be here
any second
the book is alive he woke up
if we intend to live past sunrise we
have to steal their souls
wait can we talk about this
no
we must fly
maniac obsessed with getting revenge on
salem sounds
very bad for salem
we should get some salt why so we taste
better when they eat us
[Music]
[Music]
that's not six feet under
i am a good zombie
[Music]
bye